Germany collects plenty in taxes
estimates show some 7,000 years is paid
in per person annually the money is
spent mainly on supporting those out of
work the second-largest bill is for
public dead followed by the cost of
maintaining the military is that
sensible spending name is Riley not I'd
earn more and maybe fewer potholes in
the streets fillets with vinegar a
chance to visit the cannot maybe several
things are senseless madness compared to
neighboring countries things in Germany
are going quite well surveys show that
only thirty-six percent of the people
think tax revenues are spent sensibly a
large majority of people sixty-two
percent say that the state spends
irrationally many Germans also seem to
agree that there should be more money
available to ensure greater social
justice they should thank goodness I'd
say that education is important and
social welfare as well your light
applause a bit less for the rich and a
bit more for the poor you may offer
those more for social welfare and
redistribute wealth from the top down
Methos alone one in three German
surveyed said taxes were too high and
the burden on taxpayers too great
you